je suis lyonnais norev je suis artiste
plasticien c'est à dire que je travaille
plusieurs médiums comme la peinture la
sculpture la vidéo est dans le cadre de
la nuit des musées nous allons faire une
projection sur la façade du musée
[Musique]
dans le cadre de la nuit des musées le
choix s'est porté sur une présentation
museum il ya plusieurs gars disent
qu'ils travaillent moi je travaille sur
museum donc en fait on va faire une
projection sur le musée sur le principe
un petit peu du mapping en travaillant
sur l' architecture un peu de musées
donc là vous pouvez voir le muséum donc
là l'idée c'est de créer des calques qui
correspondent un petit peu aux
différents éléments d'architecturé donc
on a là les colonnes là j'ai fait les
fenêtres le fonds du musée par exemple
et l'idée en fait ses dents suite est
inséré des des vidéos pour faire vivre
un peu le lapassade durant la mini en
fait je me suis intéressé un petit peu
aux animaux qui sont dans la musique
parce que c'est un muséum d'histoire
naturelle des jeux
je pensais évoluer un petit peu dans le
monde sous marin dans le monde des
méduses dans les mondes
des animaux luminescents des animaux qui
font la lumière dans les profondeurs
[Musique]
alors moi dans mon travail j'aime bien
finalement créé des petits instants de
magie comme ça et de faire une
projection comme ça sur le muséum c'est
intéressant de montrer une autre
lisibilité d'un lieu de voir ce lieu la
nuit est de créer un petit moment de
magie pour cette soirée c'est aussi pour
voir toucher un plus grand public on va
dire sur cette nuit des musées
oui voilà donc en fait la nuit des
musées qui est un principe intéressant
d'aller visiter les musées la nuit en
important des performances artistiques
comme ça on touche un plus grand public
et c'est assez intéressant
[Musique]